العلاقات الايرانيه
الاذريه تزداد تازما والسبب انشطه تخريبيه
قام بها ايرانيون في اذربيجان الخبر اعلنت
عنه وزاره الداخليه الاداريه التي اكدت
اعتقاله 39 شخصا قاموا بتنفيذ انشطه
تخريبيه في اذربيجان تتمثل الانشطه في
الترويج لصالح ايران على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي واساءه استخدام الحريه الدينيه
في البلاد فضلا عن تنفيذ مهمات لصالح
اجهزه الامن الايرانيه تاتي هذه العمليه
اياما قليله فقط بعد العمليه الخاصه التي
تم خلالها ضبط شبكه تابعه للمخابرات
الايرانيه في اذربيجان واعتقال سبعه اشخاص
يبدو الموضوع اكبر من مجرد عمليتين خاصتين
بل يتعلق بحمله واسعه النطاق لكشف شبكه
تجسس ايرانيه تقول باكو ولا يبدو بان
الملف قد اغلق فوزاره الداخليه الاذريه اع
هذه الحمله المكثفه هي مستمره في باكو
ومدن اخرى في البلاد تصعيد ماكو ضد طهران
تواصل حيث اوسط وزاره الخارجيه الاثريه
رعاياها بالامتناع عن السفر الى ايران اذا
لم تكن لديهم ضروره قصوه توصيه جاءت هذه
المره على خلفيه الهجوم المسلحه على سفاره
اذربيجان في طهران والذي وقع يوم الجمعه
الماضيه هو الهجوم الذي اعاد الى الواجهه
الخلافات المتعدده بين اذربيجان وايران
ابرز هذه الخلافات اتهامه طهران بتاجيج ان
ساعات الانفصاليه على اراضيها من خلال
الاقليه الاذريه المتواجده شمال غرب ايران
كما ان طهران تتوجه من التعاون العسكري
بين اذربيجان واسرائيل التي تعد مزوده
مهما للاسلحه الى باكو فضلا عن تخوفها من
امكانيه استخدام تل ابيب الاراضي الاذريه
للتحرك ضد